[Music]
in mid-flight stretch news submitted by
I made it ma you so rich a woman annoyed
fellow passengers by doing yoga in the
aisle during her flight is gonna be god
I hate tonight
I am guilty I do this way in the aisle
you also just do random punches and
kicks that's annoying
kick is I do like writing you're like
[ __ ] going like randomly he does like
spin kicks and [ __ ] just like I don't
know why I need to stay sharp but I've
never seen you do that the aisle though
now don't do kicks in the aisle seen you
do it like in the rest sections right
right by the bathroom you can't get that
right no no no I I do this old man
stretches I stretch - yeah she did it in
the aisle way if she's good-looking
I think awesome and she's wearing yoga
pants yeah
but if she's not be careful that is so
honest of you that's very honest cuz I
would probably enjoy if she was hot
y'all be like oh god attention [ __ ] but
I'm watching ya then you turn on the
light you twist even as a woman what
even as a woman you would look at a hot
girl do yoga of course why not
I appreciate women yeah yeah because I
can't appreciate a like a really buff
looking handsome man doing that [ __ ]
yeah you probably would but you would be
you wouldn't categorize it as oh this
guy's attractive no I'd be like get to
sit the [ __ ] down buff guy depends it
depends cuz it feels like [ __ ]
Matthew McConaughey I'm alone cuz he's
just so [ __ ] cool I expect him to
just stand up and start doing yoga on a
flight yeah I gotta get this man have a
woman's butt I'll look at that disease
rolling that booger in his finger
someone took a video of her stretching
what a pervert
look at this pervert oh this [ __ ] is
extras [ __ ] wow she's extra like that
she get her role too she's doing all the
transitional moves she's doing a Cirque
show in the middle of the plane why did
she just go to the back oh she needs to
get kicked in the [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
kick coming right fast zoom in this is
like the kid who brings the guitar to
lunch okay we get it now you're the
[ __ ] best look at that guy looking
back I'll give it to her flexible she's
a yoga teacher oh I'll give it to her
like she's got confidence she doesn't
give a [ __ ] and she lives in her own
world she's not getting in anyone's way
really well you are cuz you're not
supposed to be blocking the aisles at
any time because it's a fire hazard but
really she's not really dude so far
hazard how long was she do on a plane
there you know are you [ __ ] hazardous
you can get him out of there on a plane
that everything's a [ __ ] block so
it's over yeah you did okay so she was
flying I probably know do yoga in front
of me she's got like pretzel legs on
sideways pretzel legs on sideways
everybody are so dope dude hey guys
we're gonna take it in to pretzel legs
on side and then we're gonna do the
croissant on the back to the [ __ ] me in
the ass to Oregon I want you to wrap
your arms around just like crazy cousin
language is trying to get a great
picture yeah so there are a lot of
people on the YouTube comments
complaining saying no one needs to see
people falling about on planes not your
living room on the flip side I don't
know I don't think it's that bad yeah
like going like that like people are
taking it either way to hear a way to
hear is because on the internet you have
to take a stand
well that's right you have to
it's either you support her and they're
gonna donate to her goal fund her or you
want to kill her for me that's just
hilarious it's just like wow this person
is out of her [ __ ] mind it's not
enough to be like this [ __ ] yeah cuz
there was a there are people like oh wow
you attention [ __ ] or saying something
like calling her [ __ ]
if you told me that this was instead
like she did this in the aisles and then
they did it go fund me to get her a yoga
studio so she could do this and I would
believe that too yes
My gods how [ __ ] weird this world is
if if she was doing that [ __ ] and she's
like I'm on that aisle seat I would ask
her to like I would finally say like can
you please just do that over there cuz I
want to hear her breathing like is that
gentleman that's sitting right next to
that how dare she subjected to that fat
ass that's true attempting fair ass it's
disgusting I absolutely hate it in fact
you should go to jail but what if uh as
a yoga instructor her doing that is like
us doing this just you know like a
little might be but you don't do it in
the aisle you have the common courtesy
that she knows it's extra man she knows
you're supposed to beat your kids at
your house not in public
mmm true and I won't go for a minute
I'll do maybe about 30 seconds I do the
whole like like this because even like
people who hit their kids in public they
just grab their palm and they pierce
their [ __ ] palms with their thumb and
then they do the real beating at home
exactly yeah that's true they have the
decency to not do it in public put my
[ __ ] seat back I try to be less such
a good steward on the play
really yeah barely you're nice yeah I
always feel kind of guilty especially
when it's like uh like when and you
could tell he was eating comfortable and
I feel a little bit guilty like sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry I'm doing
it all oh I don't do that at all I
cocked that [ __ ] back like a
[ __ ] take off that's like [ __ ]
me running
what happens is this you'll go up and
they go alright so we're at I've been
waiting like [ __ ] man you wish you went
that far back like this I've been
waiting yeah that's so true
I've been wait
just airplanes are probably the only
real reason that I would like to lose
like dramatic like dramatic weight
because like you own a gym or some [ __ ]
right like Jesus like you'll get a
membership right yeah do you ever feel
like all the way back right do you feel
like you're like this all the time like
this the most uncommon Tet if you're fat
or you're but as long as you're wide
you're uncomfortable [ __ ] well part
these guys have all short people's
privilege oh that's right everything is
first class no you're sure people yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
even though I do think that the size
changed because I recently flew American
Airlines and I was like I don't remember
it being this small tray tables like my
legs are too big for the trailer does
your tray table go at an angle like way
always right I used to be able to go
like this and knocked out I remember I
used to be comfortable
maybe you got taller no I won't say that
since I've gotten older now like in my
30s now it's like being able to sleep in
any angle ain't the same like I used to
be able to sleep in coach and like sure
I could figure it out but now it's like
oh my neck or whatever stupid [ __ ] I
make fun of myself before any of you can
it's weird though right like when you
get older like you get things get stuck
it's like what the [ __ ] why is my neck
stuff it's weird all the time like if I
say well we've all watch movies well we
got a movie I'm sitting there for like
two hours and then when I get up I feel
like my knees are so stiff but I kind of
like I need an exit it's only for two
hours we're not talking about like a
international
flight I know we're talking about like
being on playing people even better
shape than you yeah but I don't know if
I would have seen this lady on the plane
I'd have been like all right cool it do
your thing whatever but yeah like like
geo said if she was right next to me
blank you because that that's that's
part of the yoga it's the breathing yeah
I'd be laughing too hard to be at me how
do giving her five bucks yeah I would've
slit right yeah hundred percent why not
that's right you know what it is it's
it's it's the amount of you have to
balance out confrontation versus what
you're gonna get from it right yeah so
if I if she's just gonna stretch for
three minutes I'm not gonna give a [ __ ]
but it's a 30-minute session if it's a
30-minute session there but hey [ __ ]
because I had to endure it for this you
know what are you enduring Lily the
sideways Metzl let me tell you this if
my wife or if your girlfriend's past
right then it I think you could be like
yeah oh this is what it is I don't care
because if I'm sitting at the aisle this
is what I picture right so I'm just
trying to chill this is no the [ __ ]
leg moving that [ __ ] dude I was on that
international flight is a long one and
there's this asian lady behind me who
had like a little stereo and they're
playing like [ __ ] she was playing like a
little bit of little music from it like
pretty loud cuz oh my god it could be
your mom playing or [ __ ] long and it
was like a chanting music it was like
like did you wear Bruno Mars not with
like sunglasses yes she had the Bruno
Mars my god but [ __ ] it was like a
pink pink one of those mine a bit of his
mom could've been but then just but then
it was like a little bit of like like
yeah that [ __ ] oh man where was out from
Singapore to America yeah she wearing a
shape-ups
you know let's get your shoes like this
no I wouldn't know man I don't know any
that [ __ ] she already died before that I
mean there's definitely a billion of
these people out there so like like
literally so who knows but yeah it was
pretty nuts man I was like and I didn't
even say yo [ __ ] turned your [ __ ]
music off cuz I just have I don't know I
have a respect for old people that I
can't
what kind of people they get allotted
that she's not old she's too young for
that [ __ ] she knows better
yeah if she's rubbing her [ __ ] leg
and smacking me like as I'm like trying
to chill that would be a no gonna be
annoying I wouldn't I wouldn't mind
let's just really like stop yourself
Gemma playing like there's an old person
twenties a restroom or if the cart
lady's coming down yeah otherwise it
would you know why it's cuz she didn't
do extravagant so it was too basic but
if she had like one of those things
where it's like the cloth things and she
started spinning around yeah if she did
some amazing thing I would have been
like whoa that's [ __ ] awesome look
great idea so it's gotta be next level
if she's gonna do that pretzel [ __ ]
she's got a contortion herself like it
can't be yoga she has to look like a
ball of yarn
this'll a type [ __ ] yeah it would be
exhaling super heavy around you as [ __ ]
I don't like that either man I don't
like that it's already recycle I think
you do that I feel like you're breathing
a heavy next to everybody I mean that's
why this is you off when they do it to
you did you have a breathing competition
you know I do have a habit of sleeping
on people in place well yeah dude I did
that to a guy on accident I felt
terrible I know he did but he's just so
pissed off by me I think you know don't
big guy already is when people cough
like a [ __ ] because I feel like
dude I literally did this makes it the
guy the whole time cuz he kept coffee
next to you like he was sitting yeah I
couldn't take it anything good no black
well black but he was apologetic he was
like oh sorry man so I just said oh
that's nice and I was like it's cool
good night it's like if you do this
because I'm coffee
no I'm Japanese and I'm a ninja